stücks ist unbedingt sehenswert das ist
ein zwei personen film in dem nur zwei
mehr oder weniger nur zwei darsteller
vorkommen nämlich eine umwerfende
wirklich alles wegfegen de in der ganz
ganz stimmen performance aller staaten
stellen performance die susanne wolff
und gideon wie käse ein junge aus einem
slum in nairobi wo ihn die eine eine
castingagentur entdeckt hat
erstmal ist es eigentlich lange nur
susanne wolff und zwar als
einhandseglerin auf dem atlantik also
eine selbstbewusste starke
professionelle frau die sich eben
alleine auf den weg macht von gibraltar
nach essenziell dass kommen
zwischendurch mal einen sturm aber auch
den bringt sie hinter sich ohne das
große erschütterung zu erleben wären bei
ihr und nach diesem sturm guckt sie aus
dem fenster und sieht so ungefähr eine
seemeile entfernt ein flüchtlingsschiff
damit ist so quasi das problem mit dem
wir uns sowieso täglich beschäftigen in
den nachrichten eben plötzlich auf ihrem
boot gelandet das ganze ist aber von
einer solchen spielerischen qualität
dass man wirklich das gefühl hat wird
nicht eine nachrichten situation
sozusagen noch mal im spielfilm
kommuniziert seiner man hat den eindruck
jede möglichkeit auch der symbolisierung
wird ein gestiegenes liegen gelassen und
also es gibt keine musik die uns erzählt
was wir fühlen sollen sondern es gibt
nur der film arbeitet nur mit original
geräuschen
es ist aber natürlich alles sehr
wackelig und man merkt dass da nicht
gespielt wird dass es ruckelig ist oder
das ist das ist heftig heftiger wind
weht und dass die beiden über das boot
über dem boot zusammen schlagen das ist
eine ganz ganz dichte atmosphäre die
aber eben völlig und manipulative ist
das ist glaube das ist das wesentliche
an diesem film dass er überhaupt nicht
manipuliert
[Musik]